I HELPED A PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR
NAMED BRIAN WOLFE
WHO WASN'T TOO FOND
OF MY NATURAL PERSONALITY.
- YOU'RE IN A [bleep] PINK SHIRT
AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
OH, YOU'RE KILLING ME.
- BUT NOW, THANKS TO THE ADVICE
OF A DIVERSE FOCUS GROUP,
I WAS ABLE TO TRANSFORM
INTO A MORE LIKABLE PERSON.
SO FOR MY FINAL TEST,
I VISITED BRIAN AT HIS HOME
TO SEE WHAT HE THOUGHT OF
THE NEW ME.
SO I'VE COME A LONG WAY SO FAR,
THANKS TO YOU.
BEFORE I GO IN TONIGHT
TO TALK TO BRIAN,
I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
DO I LOOK OKAY?
IS ALL THE...OUTFIT?
- YOU LOOK GOOD.
YOU'RE DRESSED, AGAIN--
IT FITS YOU PERFECT,
THE V-NECK AND THE BLAZER.
- THIS IS GOOD?
- YEAH. IT FITS YOU.
IT FITS YOU.
- OKAY. AND SO THIS IS ME.
- THIS IS YOU.
BE PROUD OF WHO YOU ARE.
- WITH THOSE ENCOURAGING WORDS,
I MARCHED INTO BRIAN'S HOUSE
TO SEE IF MY NEW PERSONALITY
WOULD WIN HIM OVER.
BRIAN.
- NATHAN. HOW YOU DOING?
HOW YOU BEEN?
- I WANT TO TELL YOU SOMETHING,
BRIAN.
LAST TIME I WAS HERE,
I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS.
- OKAY.
- AND I WASN'T REALLY
BEING MYSELF.
SO I THOUGHT
WE COULD DO THIS AGAIN.
- OKAY.
- AND THIS TIME,
YOU CAN GET TO KNOW
THE REAL ME.
- LOOK AT YOU.
YOU'RE STILL A GOOBER,
BUT THAT'S JUST YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
- WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT,
GOOBER?
WHAT'S THAT MEAN?
- GOOBER JUST MEANS
LIKE A DORK, A NERD.
- I'M A NERD.
- YOU KNOW YOU'RE A NERD.
YOU'VE BEEN A NERD
YOUR ENTIRE LIFE.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH BEING A [bleep] NERD.
YOU'RE A NERD.
- I'M NOT A NERD.
- ALL RIGHT, WELL, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S MY OPINION.
SERIOUSLY, IF I THREW A FOOTBALL
AT YOU RIGHT NOW,
YOU THINK YOU COULD CATCH IT?
- I COULD CATCH THE FOOTBALL.
- YOU CAN CATCH A FOOTBALL?
- YEAH.
- I DOUBT IT.
I DOUBT YOU CAN CATCH
A FOOTBALL.
- BRIAN STILL DIDN'T LIKE ME.
AND AFTER ALL THE WORK
I HAD DONE, I DIDN'T KNOW WHY.
- DON'T BE SAD.
IT'S OKAY.
- THEN, WHEN I RETURNED
TO THE TRUCK,
I WAS SHOCKED TO DISCOVER
THAT THE GROUP WAS TRYING TO
DISTANCE THEMSELVES
FROM THEIR OWN SUGGESTIONS.
- IT'S TOO LOW.
THE V-NECK.
IT'S JUST TOO LOW.
- WHY DIDN'T YOU SPEAK UP
BEFORE?
I ASKED BEFORE I WENT IN
IF THIS WAS GOOD.
- I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS GONNA BE
THAT LOW, MAN.
- WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
YOU DIDN'T LIKE THE V-NECK?
- NOT THAT LOW.
- I ASKED YOU GUYS
BEFORE I WENT IN WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THIS LOOK?
- V-NECK IS THIS, NOT HERE.
- YOU GUYS SAID
YOU LIKED THE LOOK.
- IT FITS YOU PERFECTLY,
V-NECK AND THE BLAZER.
- THAT'S WHEN I REALIZED
THERE WAS A MAJOR FLAW
WITH MY ENTIRE EXPERIMENT.
THIS NEW PERSONALITY
WAS BASED ON THE JUDGMENT
OF FOUR PEOPLE WHO HAD AGREED
TO WORK OUT OF THE BACK
OF A MOVING BOX TRUCK.
OF COURSE IT WAS FLAWED.
IN THE END, MAYBE
THERE WAS NOTHING I COULD DO
TO BECOME THE GUY
THAT EVERYONE LOVES.
BUT FOR A BRIEF MOMENT IN TIME,
IT FELT NICE THINKING
THAT I HAD A CHANCE.
CAN I GET A LITTLE
RUBBY-DUB-DUB?
- HO HO HO HO!
- NICE.
- GOOD ONE.
GOOD ONE.
- ALL RIGHT.
[upbeat music]